great everyone I'm Ilana and welcome to
my youtube channel today I'm going to be
talking about something that I've been
doing for a couple of years now where I
basically take screenshots of messages
that kids send me and send them to their
parents the reason I specifically wanted
to talk about this right now is because
almost exactly two years ago I tweeted
out one of them others reactions and
that tweet got quite a bit of traction
but because it's like the anniversary I
guess it's showing up people's Facebook
feeds again and websites who shed it to
just trying to make money off of very
inflammatory headlines related to rape
and violence and someone call me a
snitch and all that good stuff sharing
them on Facebook again which means that
I get an influx of people asking me
questions and being weirdly angry and a
whole lot more rape threats so basically
how this all happened is that I get
write threats every now and then on the
internet people say that they would
break me if they ever saw me before I
started with the screenshot strategy I
just used to block these people and not
pay a whole lot of attention to it but
then one day a kid messaged my facebook
page and he had his profile picture
which led me to realize how young most
of the people who say this kind of [ __ ]
off so what kind of a code to me that
well yeah I still think he was saying it
to try and get my attention it was also
that he probably do realize the
implications of what he was saying or
what it meant or why that's a [ __ ] up
thing to say to someone and so I went on
his profile his mother was listed under
family on the side very often very very
easy to find people's parents or details
on Facebook pages and so I sent her a
screenshot of what he had said and
phrased it very carefully to say
something like hey a son has said this
to me
maybe you want to discuss this with him
so it was half with the intention of
being like this person is young I could
influence what that's saying and stop
them from saying this again but on the
other side it was like me having this
evil laughter about how I was gonna get
this kid in trouble for doing something
shitty to me so
I found his mom on his Facebook page I
messaged her on Facebook Messenger and
she replied and said she would deal with
it and that was that I've contacted
quite a few people in this period of
time for a lot of those people the
message to sat in an inbox that they
couldn't see so they didn't reply some
parents would respond to me very
aggressively and say that I must have
done something to provoke it or
otherwise say that that's not true it's
not their son it's it's got to be made
up the best outcome I had was of course
because that tweet was picked up by a
lot of news outlets the mother involved
took it very seriously she ended up
having a meeting with her school board
and spoke to parents and teachers alike
about basically how to monitor what kids
are saying online without invading their
privacy and she also made him write me a
letter of apology which was very very
nice the third most common question is
probably why don't you go to the police
in these kinds of situations the police
unfortunately don't do anything well
can't do anything well so I personally
don't believe that these people actually
intend to harm me I think they just want
my attention still think saying
something like that just for attention
is shitty which is why I really like the
idea that by doing this by contacting
families or girlfriends in some shitty
cases all schools that you can give
real-world consequences to [ __ ] that
happens online and you know if this
teacher is a kid to not say that they're
going to rape someone again in the
future even colloquially but I'm pretty
happy with that also he got super
grounded and was kicked off of Xbox Live
for a while so I'm also pretty happy
with that and on that note the final
criticism that I get the most is if you
can't [ __ ] handle it get off the
internet in response to that I would say
I mean this didn't upset me I think I
did handle it I handled it pretty well
I'm happy with the way that I handled it
but I also wouldn't blame other people
for kind of being upset about it and I
don't think the solution is to ever
leave the Internet it's such a pivotal
part of our lives at this point it's so
important to my job if anything it's how
we communicate it's how people network
it's helped people get jobs at this
I think telling people not to go online
or to log off or to ignore it
is ridiculous so yeah that is how I did
it that is how I felt about it thank you
guys so much for watching I do also have
to give a shout out to the people who
have supported my channel over the past
month
Mathew domain us for the third time I
think thank you so much Matthew your
incredible mega Chu one one seven Ralph
a Mullin who coincidentally said he
found out about my channel because of
this internet thing Rob Cameron who also
asked me to say the most cliche thing in
the world that's not a knife this is a
knife but I assume you want it in full
blown stereotypical Australian accent so
um that's not a knife this is a knife
and then one last person who asked me
not to shut them out but did ask me to
by Chelsea a treat with their donations
so yeah I will but those who don't know
channel supporting is basically a thing
way you can donate to your favorite
youtubers if you want to I think the
link is on my about page only works in
certain countries but to everyone who
has done that so far thank you guys so
much it makes an enormous difference and
really encourages me to get my button
here and try and make more YouTube
videos thank you guys forever and of
course thank you to everyone who watches
my videos in general I will see you guys
next time